i'm just getting started darling disney
took a page out of your favorite 2000s
rom-com for their newest live-action
cruella
they showed us just who put the deville
in the devil wears prada
there were moments in their newest
villain backstory that were too similar
not to compare from cruella and andrea
being very similar characters
to the devilish and eerily identical
fashion in both films
you won't ever be able to look at either
movie the same way again
you're going to have to be more specific
what
there's nothing like a good morning
montage something both cruella and the
devil wears prada
gave to us in their opening minutes the
context of the two scenes couldn't be
any more different cruella is getting
ready for a day of some good old
criminal activity
and andy is preparing for a
life-changing job interview
but there are moments that are almost
identical
just look at the two women taking a bite
of their bagels or
strutting across public transit it's
your classic
movie moment a small town girl arrives
in the big city with all of their hopes
and dreams
they stare up at the big buildings all
around them
and walk into the next stage of their
life ironically
this moment was filmed the exact same
way in both films
check it out little did they know what
hardships lay ahead
dalmatians and starbucks orders when
andy
lands her job at runway and cruella at
liberty the two are treated like
servants cruella is forced to work on
her hands and knees
literally and even gets trash thrown at
her at one point
really we couldn't help but compare this
to how andy was
also forced to do all the dirty work at
first and while she didn't get trash
thrown her way
there were a whole lot of flying jackets
they were also both under the orders of
workers who were very bossy
i really did everything i could think of
uh
emma thompson is a huge reason why
cruella was
so epic while she brought the original
character of the baroness to life
we couldn't help but think of meryl
streep's miranda priestly and her wicked
ways
even more similar was how people reacted
whenever they arrived at their offices
right down to the script just look at
how similar these two scenes are
even the way they step out of their cars
is identical
she's coming the baroness she's out
front the way work life is portrayed in
both these movies is so
interchangeable we probably wouldn't
have noticed if they were swapped the
sound of heels clicking
paper shuffling and people constantly
running around to meet the needs of
their ungrateful bosses
in other words chaotic another thing to
notice is how the camera uses an angle
that lets us know cruella and andrea
are 100 overwhelmed
it wouldn't be a film about the fashion
industry without bosses like the
baroness
and miranda terrorizing their designers
for just
not bringing their a game at least when
it comes to cruella and the devil wears
prada
in cruella the baroness marches past all
of her options
similarly to how miranda asks her
designers to come up with all their best
ideas
on the spot don't believe us take a look
i see you think this has nothing to do
with you
cruella was sent into panic mode when
the baroness gave her a very
very very specific lunch order
just like when andy had to somehow come
up with the perfect steak to surf
miranda
in just 15 minutes they both panicked
understandably but got it done
just look at them rushed through the
restaurants what's even eerier is that
both the baroness
and miranda basically dismiss their
perfect meals
as if they weren't more difficult to get
than an unpublished harry potter
manuscript
we have all the published harry potter
books twins want to know what happens
next
cruella didn't exactly get a formal
interview with the baroness
it was more of a you destroyed my shop
window but here's my card anyway
type of situation however there were
plenty of moments where she was
interrogated
by the baroness that we couldn't help
but find familiar
don't these scenes remind you of when
andy has her interview with miranda and
runway
both superiors are nonchalant and
uninterested but can still see the
potential in both young ladies
granted one of the bosses was a little
more
physically violent than the other who
doesn't love
a good transformation tuesday can we all
talk about cruella's robe going
up in flames to reveal her stunning red
gown how very katniss everdeen of her
what was even better to see was the
reaction of everyone around her
they were speechless do you know what it
reminded us of
you guessed it andy's designer
transformation
while she wasn't under disguise the
reactions from her co-workers were
basically the same
shocked just look at their faces
both cruella and the devil wears prada
deal with the corrupt fashion industry
well yes cruella's version is a little
more dark and gruesome in comparison to
the
cattiness of miranda priestly's world
something funny
the world both filmmakers create is
actually
pretty similar especially when you
compare cruella to andy's trip to paris
it's all about competitiveness and
wealthy individuals trying to smooch
their way to the top
not to mention that the imagery when it
comes to the fashion show is
identical minus the decorations for each
decade of course
cruella isn't short of high class
parties the film basically starts and
ends with one
halls filled with ball gowns fancy hors
d'oeuvres and people who only care about
getting ahead
but we have to admit they're stunning to
look at miranda priestly also throws the
event
of a lifetime in devil wears prada in
both films these balls are the talk of
the town
and for all important purposes are
almost
filmed the exact same way look at them
side by side
there's no denying it bye bye estella
hello cruella while iconic
transformations aren't always a blessing
in fact for cruella it almost cost her
the only friends she'd
ever had horus and jasper in devil wears
prada andy had the same situation happen
with her boyfriend
after selling her soul to the world of
fashion in both films the two groups
have
very similar conversations take a listen
i'm mrs stella what happened now now
you've become one of them
now we're not saying that meryl streep
walked around the set of the devil wears
prada in a dalmatian patterned coat but
there were moments in cruella and the
devil wears prada where their outfits
were too
similar and on point to ignore this is
especially true when we take a look at
miranda
and the baroness off the shoulder and
high shoulders seems to be
all the rage for both characters we also
can't forget
all the coats worn through the films
there were points where cruella
as estella and the transformed andy
could have swapped closets
we were trying to figure out how it was
possible that these two movies were so
similar when we found our answer one of
the writers of the devil wears prada
actually
wrote the first draft of cruella maybe
that's the reason why what's being said
in these two scenes are so similar
everybody wants to be us everyone else
is an
obstacle not to mention the imagery of
the two women toying with their
sunglasses and getting out of their
vehicles and entering a world of fame
and wealth that they've built on false
promises
everybody wants this overall the main
characters of cruella and the devil
wears prada are just
too similar to ignore let's take a look
at estella or
cruella and andy they're both aspiring
professionals who take on a role in the
fashion industry
that leaves them abused by their bosses
and co-worker
the difference is cruella gave in to her
inner hatred
while andy used it to rise above and
pave her own way
now onto miranda and the baroness
they're both powerful
successful women who don't care who they
hurt as long as they stay at the top of
the food chain
they also both happen to be running two
very large companies tied to the fashion
industry
need we say more learning about this
stuff and
this stuff cruella
similar to the devil wears prada
groundbreaking
while there's no denying the
similarities between these two films we
can't discredit how
epic this live action was giving depth
to cruella made the classic
101 dalmatian story 101 times more
interesting than it already was
did you notice any other similarities
between the two films